[Music]  Maksim Chmerkovskiy is on the road to  recovery and stamina good following a  painful calf injury in rehearsal -  Dancing with the Stars pro shared a  selfie from his hospital bed before  heading into surgery that read getting  unbroken hopefully ditch makovski Gina's  gonna kick in and he's gonna recover  quick max has been getting medical  attention in Ohio from surgeon William a  seeds who also treated his fiancee Peta  Murgatroyd in previous seasons it was  freak accident his cough just popped it  was very weird next he's gonna get back  he's gonna kill it in the meantime  Max's partner Heather Morris and Phil in  dancing pro Alan Bernstein are moving on  to another week after nailing the jive  [Music]